♪ ♪ ♪
- On vtatatatatatatatatatatatat.
Hop! Viens-t'en!
Anabel, est-ce que tu peux venir
m'aider, s'il te plaît?
à 17 ans. Une famille de huit.
- Tu restes ici, hein?
, ça, c'est 350, hein.
Peux-tu checker sur le sac,
- Bienvenue chez les Berger-Cam.
JULIE CAMPEAU, mère de famille
tout ce qui monte, l'essence...
On doit revoir nos priorités.
- Et pour Julie, la priorité
ne manquent de rien.
- Je dois faire l'épicerie,
parce que ça manque
quelque chose. Juste en lait,
on a à peu près six poches
de lait aux deux jours.
je me permets de faire
des ventes de garage ici
à Ville Lasalle. Puis
par la suite de racheter
des vêtements aux enfants.
C'est ici que je store
Quand il y a des spéciaux,
c'est pas toujours le cas,
bien, je vais racheter
Ça, c'est mon deuxième
congélateur. Là, comme
vous pouvez voir, c'est pas
je dois refaire des provisions.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un quotidien réglé
comme du papier à musique.
sur ce qui est mon tableau,
mon calendrier, mon menu,
le calendrier scolaire,
mon agenda, mon téléphone.
- Ça aussi, on l'utilise
beaucoup.
- Julie compte aussi sur Anabel,
l'aînée de la fratrie,
- Ce que je fais, c'est que
j'ai des applications
ma fille m'a montrée récemment.
ANABEL CAMPEAU,- Je mets, je sa.
"Fraises".
Tu vois, cette semaine,
au Maxi, ils sont 4,99,
- Bien, ça me coûte
un 400 $ par semaine.
Oui. 400 $, comparativement
"v'la" quelques mois, ça pouvait
J'arrivais à faire une belle
épicerie. Bien, c'est sû
malheureusement, ça me coûte
toujours plus cher ques.s.s.s.s.
C'est comme çaieieieie.
Jamais que je vais empêchergege.
- Parce qulelelele seul salaire
de son conjoint, ça ne suffitcoé
à travaàààà temps partiel
il y a cinq mois.enenenenenenenr
mooioioioint aussi là-dedans,
parce que, excusez l'expressiont
la langue à terre, là, t'sa
- Vêtements, nourriture,
essence : autant de bienssesesee
de Julie ne peut se pass
et qui risquent de gruger
encore le budget familial.
Valeurs mobil. Banque Laurent.
- Le prix de l'essence,
probablement pour
les prochaines semaines,
ça pourrait continuer
à monter. Pour  e e e est
de la nourriture, on s'attend
à ce que ça continue d'accélérer
climatiques, de la mauvaise
récolte l'an dernier et
le coût de main-d'oeuvre.
- Est-ce que ça vous arrive
de vous priver?
Oui.
- S'en tenir à l'essentiel
pour rester à flot.
- Pour le moment,
on se débrouille quand même
sous le seuil de la pauvreté
non plus. Ça, non, non.
Puis, j'aimerais pas ça
me rendre là non plus.
Mais si jamais on arrache,
c'est sûr que... c'est sûr
et certain que...
(bruit de l'enfant)
Oui!
C'est sûr et certainiviviviviviu
des banques alimentaires.
- Si Julie erarararande famille
s'en sortent, d'autres
n'y arrivent pas.
JEAN-PAUL ururururururururururum
- On est rendu à plus de 20 %
de genonononont un salaire,
qui ont un emploi
et qui arrivent pas.
- qui cumule une expertise
de plus de 30 ans, témoigne
d'une situation sans précédent.
(soupir)
- Les prix ont tellement
quadruplé que ça n'a plus
de bon sens. Ça n'a plus
de bon sens.
Les gens ne sont pas capables
de planifier un budget.
de distribution de l'aide
alimentaire à Montréal
des choix difficiles.
n n n n en arrive présentement
à cette situation-là où il faut
choisir à qui oIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlt
ça. Il y en a d'autres qui
choisissent plutôt de diminuer
chaque panier qui est donné.
la préoccupation du momentmememr
de belles vacances en famille.
- En faisant du camping,on vienr
sur les chambres d'hôtel,
les chambres d'hôtel
sont assez dispendieuses.
Il y a bien des moyens
sans que ça coûte une fortune.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'inflation affecte peut-être
le portefeuialalalalalalalalala.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa